on va parler un peu de vous Charles de
Courson quelle trajectoire quand même
qui aurait pu imaginer que vous
défendriez vous deviendriez plutôt
l'homme qui fait trembler le
gouvernement vous êtes un peu le vétéran
de l'Assemblée le père la rigueur le
centriste et vous êtes aujourd'hui le
chouchou de la gauche regardez comment
cette trajectoire a été rendue possible
c'est dans l'invitation de Marion Becker
on en parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Charles de Courson
c'est parce que vous vivez votre heure
de gloire en quelques mois vous êtes
devenu l'attraction de l'assemblée
en défiant la macronie vous êtes devenus
la coqueluche de l'opposition
[Musique]
de la starification c'est pas mon truc
voilà qui aime les libertés et qui au
nom de ça a pris des positions fortes
depuis maintenant plusieurs années et
qui manifestement est très attaché à la
démocratie parlementaire au point de ne
pas accepter les méthodes je crois que
c'est surtout ça qui le fait réagir
aujourd'hui du gouvernement dans
l'hémicycle vous êtes autant applaudis
par la France insoumise que par le
rassemblement national
quelle ironie du sort pour vous le
député aristocrate descendant d'une
famille très engagée politiquement car
Charles de Courson ou plus précisément
Charles a met des Dubuisson de Courson
vous êtes député de la Marne depuis 1993
30 ans un an et 27 jours très
précisément tour à tour
UDF
udi non inscrit en 2018 vous avez
co-fondé le groupe Liot
longtemps surnommé le moine soldat de
l'Assemblée pour votre rigueur vous le
bourreau de travail vous êtes
incollables sur les sujets budgétaires
un traitable sur le règlement dans cette
croisade que vous menez pour les droits
du Parlement vous avez écorné votre
image quitte à vous faire des
ennemisé que chacun aurait droit à son
quart d'heure de célébrité du petit buzz
pour essayer de gagner un peu en
célébrité quitte à trahir des années de
conviction ou pendant des années il a
porté recul de l'âge de départ à la
retraite si on avait écouté le Charles
de Courson de 2013 on serait déjà à 65
ans aujourd'hui et cette image Charles
de ce qu'on vous enjouez et puis alors
ça ce sont mes neveux qui m'ont qui m'a
offert cela voilà parce que ça les a
fait beaucoup rire vous voyez
c'est assez drôle
alors on vous pose la question Charles
de course avez-vous l'âme d'un
révolutionnaire
ça vous fait sourire ça me fait rire
même vous savez pourquoi vous pose aussi
la question parce que l'un de vos aïeux
Louis Michel Le Peltier de Saint-Fargeau
député sous la Révolution député noble a
voté l'exécution de Louis XVI alors il y
a quand même quelque chose peut-être
d'une âme révolutionnaire chez vous ou
pas il a voté la mort du roi comme
beaucoup il a été assassiné le lendemain
il n'avait qu'une fille qui était petite
et cette petite fille a été amenée
devant l'Assemblée nationale et elle a
été fait fille de la nation
et et moi je suis très indépendant
d'esprit j'ai toujours appartenu à des
groupes
dans lequel on avait la liberté de vote
et il n'est pas encore né celui qui me
dictera ce que je dois faire ça on l'a
bien compris un homme libre attaché
viscéralement aux droits du Parlement je
crois qu'on l'a bien compris dans ce
premier débat la rupture est totale
entre le groupe lyaute et le camp
macroniste aujourd'hui nous aurons
toujours été dans une opposition
constructive par exemple on est en train
de discuter la loi de programmation
militaire nous avons dit que nous
voterions pour la loi de programmation
militaire nous avons aidé le
gouvernement sur le texte sur les
énergies renouvelables et on a eu des
discussions on a tenu compte d'une
partie de nos observations donc nous
sommes des gens ouverts et avec Emmanuel
Macron
moi je n'ai aucune relation je n'ai
jamais discuté avec le président de la
République n'a jamais essayé de vous
appeler de vous rencontrer
d'ailleurs publiquement ce que je pense
oui parce que vous avez la denture
brutale sur les retraites c'est la
manière dont il exerces le pouvoir ou
c'est la personne que vous n'aimez pas
non c'est l'exercice non la personne
chacun ses qualités ses défauts c'est
l'exercice la façon dont il exerce le
pouvoir cette conception verticale je
dis parfois même égélienne c'est cette
croyance que parce que ton la tête de
l'État et que l'État et l'incarnation de
la raison dans l'histoire et que on va
pouvoir le faire piquer mais ça c'est
pas une démocratie moderne aussi moderne
c'est d'accepter les contre-pouvoirs de
jouer avec eux de trouver les bons
compromis qui permettent de vivre
ensemble et le président Macron n'a
cessé que d'affaiblir les corps
intermédiaires il n'aime pas le
Parlement vous pensez il n'a jamais fait
partie donc il connaît pas trop comment
ça fonctionne si vous voulez il a eu
pendant son premier mandat une forte
majorité puisque son seul parti était
majoritaire elles étaient 310 voilà donc
ils avaient la majorité absolue alors là
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce que
son parti disons les 150 sièges et avec
les autres ils sont à peu près 250 quoi
grosso modo c'est pas avec 250 que vous
pouvez imposer votre volonté donc faut
discuter
voilà vous alerter vous dites attention
cette crise des retraites va laisser des
traces la démocratie et le Parlement
vont peut-être être abîmés durablement
beaucoup estiment aussi dans cette crise
que ce sont aussi les institutions qui
sont à bout de souffle et que cette
crise le révèle notamment la Cinquième
République vous êtes d'accord avec ça
si vous voulez que c'est vrai que nos
institutions au fond n'ont pas choisi
entre un régime présidentiel et un
régime parlementaire en fait c'est un
régime semi-présidentiel qui est
présidentielle quand le président une
majorité absolue et qui est plutôt par
le mental quand il n'a pas la majorité
absolue donc le problème c'est ce qu'il
faut rester dans cette situation
par deux fois on a eu une période de
cohabitation qui serait plus ou moins
bien passé si vous voulez et là on a une
situation tout à fait originale un
président réélu pas bien d'ailleurs et
sa majorité
présidentielle sortante qui est mis en
minorité il a fait 25% des voix
l'ensemble des candidats au législatif
on fait 25% des 47% qui sont venus voter
donc dans une démocratie équilibrée
comment voulez-vous gouverner et
pour un changement d'exercice du pouvoir
ou carrément de République non je crois
que il faudrait par exemple faire une
dose de proportionnelle on peut pas
accepter que pendant des années des
courants significatifs n'est
pratiquement aucun député c'est malsain
pour la descendance
finalement oui mais il a fallu qu'ils
atteignent 25 % des voix pour avoir des
députés alors on entendait Eric Coquerel
tout à l'heure les mêmes choses pour les
Verts je ne suis pas vert mais je trouve
qu'il n'est pas normal qu'un courant tel
que les vers doivent
l'existence d'un groupe parlementaire à
des alliances avec d'autres alors que à
la proportionnelle bon bah s'ils font
10%
qu'ils aient un certain nombre de
députés c'est tout à fait normal 30 ans
à l'Assemblée nationale 30 ans dans
votre circonscription de la Marne que
vous aussi venez ne font en comble
toutes les semaines dans tous les sens
vous prenez très peu de vacances comment
vous jugez le regard que les français
portent sur leurs élus de défiance
aujourd'hui et même parfois plein de
violence si vous voulez quand on regarde
les sondages sur la perception de la
classe politique comme on l'appelle par
nos concitoyens c'est terrible puisque
je crois qu'on est à presque 75% qui
déclare que les parlementaires sont des
menteurs qui sont là pour profiter de
leur situation voilà et qui n'ont rien à
faire des problèmes de la vie concrète
et la vie réelle de nos concitoyens
c'est terrible
parce que si vous poussez cette analyse
ce qui me disent cela je dis et tu me
mets dans l'eau ah non non toi tu es un
cas par vous voyez c'est le racisme qui
dit j'aime pas les Noirs mais j'ai un
copain noir c'est à peu près la même
chose
alors moi je pense qu'il y a un
changement si vous voulez de
comportement d'avoir une plus grande
stabilité par la proportionnelle pour au
moins qu'on ait des parlementaires qui
soient stables vous savez dans la
segmentature la moitié des députés sont
nouveaux donc et l'espérance de vie d'un
député c'est un mandat et demi
je voudrais revenir un peu sur votre
trajectoire institutionnel à mon avis
qu'il faut faire si on veut sauver la
démocratie on entendait Coquerel qui dit
que vous êtes avant tout un homme libre
fils d'un résistant qui a été maire de
votre village pendant plus de 30 ans
votre grand-père Lionel Demoustier a été
le seul député de droite à voter contre
les pleins pouvoirs à Pétain en 19 40
avant d'être arrêté par la Gestapo puis
déportés en Allemagne dans un camp de
concentration où il est mort en 1945 un
mois je vous sens très émue je suis
désolé avant la libération de ce camp
c'est cette histoire de force et de
courage exceptionnel qui vous a qui vous
a forgé
oui vous savez on est
pour partie le produit d'une tradition
familiale du côté de ma mère et du côté
de mon père mais voyez nous étions 6
enfants nous sommes tous très différents
vous voyez moi j'ai pas réagi de la de
la même façon que que d'autres moi j'ai
certains des membres de ma propre
famille qui comprennent pas que je
puisse être député
c'est un métier de chien quand on est
honnête j'aurais gagné beaucoup plus
d'argent je serai PDG d'une grande boîte
mais c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse vous
voyez alors c'est peut-être aussi cela
mais les gens sont très différents donc
ça influencé mais c'est aussi une
décision personnelle vous savez quand on
l'a proposé de me présenter la première
fois dans mon village comme conseiller
municipal j'ai beaucoup hésité la
plupart d'ailleurs de mes amis m'ont dit
fait surtout pas ça ça n'a aucun intérêt
voyez
je ne regrette pas
en tous les cas voilà vous êtes un élu
depuis 30 ans ici apprécié par vos
administrés et c'est rare et il faut le
souligner